hello everybody so today's session I
decided to call from novice to data
ninja because the plan is to learn a lot
of different data tricks that you can
hopefully use in your own work and the
reason for this tutorial is that I've
seen a lot of tutorials which are Python
and time series analysis Python and
image processing Python networks but
okay you have to go to all this tutorial
separately and sometimes you just don't
have the time or sometimes you think you
don't need it so that's why you don't go
so my thinking is you never know what
you're going to need so the idea is
within two hours to try to go to
different data and how we can use it in
title so that kind of you get prepared
at least know where to start in the
future so that's kind of the plan for
today and today we have several
notebooks that we'll use and in order to
get those notebooks you can go to the
following address which are just
outputting a second
Wow
so this is a can you see in the back let
me try to make it bigger
um I don't know right okay I made bigger
than the dresses on become bigger well
let me try
so this is the address of the repository
where I have stored the materials so if
you have a github installed you can go
and clone this repository and directly
work from it if you don't you can go to
the website and click on now a download
button somewhere clone or download so
basically if you've already used github
you know how to do it most probably if
you haven't used github you can just
download the whole folder and you're
going to have several notebooks inside
this folder and you'll be able to use
them for your work so does this make
sense and then you can kind of follow
together with me you don't have to like
on the reset of everything but if you
want to play with the notebooks
it's better to get them for yourself so
apart from the actual repository we'll
be using a few data set so there links
here to a found data set in the video
data set so you can download them now or
you can wait later when we reach to them
then you can go and download them when
when you need them and you can put them
in a folder called data that I have here
and if you want to look at the link
which is again so people are getting
these materials okay okay I'll start on
I'll start on talking and in the
meantime you can kind of finish up
getting things and please if you have
any questions let me know
so basically on in order to start
working with these notebooks I assume
you have a little bit title knowledge in
a sense that or knowledge from another
programming language in a sense that you
must probably have already Python
installed and I assume that you have
installed a like anaconda Python but
most probably going to work with another
version you just need to change a few
things maybe and in general I assume you
already use the Python notebook if you
haven't it's basically pretty easy you
just you open a terminal and kind of
cutting this out
let's go
so basically you can run from the
terminal Jupiter notebook and you're
going to get the notebooks open as
people used to just to get an idea how
people use Python before okay all right
so yeah if you haven't I think still you
can kind of look at the libraries and
follow the talk independently yes yeah
kind of got stuck so it's not useful
right now anyway
and I want to make these bees
so from the terminal you just run
Jupiter notebook and that opens like a
browser and from the browser you can go
ahead and we'll start with the spatial
network notebook so basically you click
on it and you can start using it and you
can basically click on every cell and
run the cell with Shift + Enter
so pretty much that's it so ok so the
first topic on is spatial networks and
do you want me to make this bigger for
the people in the back aisle to make it
a little bit bigger
that's okay so basically we have a few
simple goals for the first part is that
we're going to learn how to deal with
data that spatial and we're going to
build some sort of network for these
data and we're going to visualize the
data in the network and we're going to
learn some features for this data set
from on the network so that's kind of
the goal
so basically simple introduction to
dealing with spatial data and networks
okay so the first part is to load a few
packages that are very common so these
are matplotlib don't buy pandas these
are packages that are used almost every
time nothing special and then we will go
and get a data set which is in the data
folder of this repository and the name
of this data set is state capitals dot
CSV so this data set on you can actually
look at it from the data folder
so
so just a text file and what it contains
is the state the state capital and the
latitude and longitude
obey very simple data set very small
data set so we are going to read this
data set in a Python and in order to do
that we're going to use a function from
the pandas library so it's read CSV
function and when we do that step we
basically have the data set stored in
the data variable so we can kind of have
a look at what's inside from Python so
we see that we have four columns with
the names in the coordinates and that's
in general how you read CSV files so
next let's try to plot these data on the
so that we visualize it pretty much all
we need to do is take these coordinates
the longitude and latitude and treat
them as x and y coordinates and plot
them on on a simple plot so this is not
a map I'm just plotting them is its
points in r2
ok so they just give it like a sort of
an outline of the country and you see
that there's like on there is Alaska and
Hawaii and basically we see that there
is some structure in this with these
points and we can say that there is
maybe some connectivity right like basil
like if we set some boundaries we can
say that some nodes are closer and some
are further away so in order to do that
so the next kind of exercises that we're
going to calculate the distance between
every two points in this data set
and we're going to build a graph from
this distance so this is kind of tree in
general if you have spatial data you can
actually build a graph using the
distance between the point so how do we
how do we calculate distances between
points can somebody volunteer to say in
general we have latitudes and longitudes
of these points
we calculate the distance so I heard
great circle somewhere so yeah we we
cannot just do reading on our distance
we need to kind of walk along the circle
because the earth is round and
technically the earth is not even a
sphere so there's like a there's a
Jewett so it depends where you are but
for the sake of this tutorial we'll
assume that it's a sphere and we'll
approximate the distance by walking on a
on a great circle so how do we do that
well there is actually a formula for
that so the main point is just to use
the formula and it caught on the heifer
sign formula it's one way to do that
there are more precise formulas but the
idea that every time you get some sort
of use geographic coordinates you have
to use these formula to calculate
distances and I'll know when I'm get
into the details of the formula you can
kind of review it but a bunch of sines
and cosines and so on and you have to
convert the latitude and longitude to
radians first and then do the
calculation so once you have that you
actually have the correct distance so as
I say in the next step basically I
create a little function which is called
spherical distance and I pretty much do
all these calculations of sines and
cosines and so on and I use the radius
to adjust for the radius of the earth
and I get my little function to
calculate distances between two points
and I take this function so in order to
test it I need to extract I need to
extract two sets of coordinates and
because we got the data into this
panda's data frame it's a little bit a
little bit irritating to work with it
but okay this specifies that I want to
get the columns latitude and longitude
and this I log think just indicate that
I want the first variable in the set
and one so I just took the first and the
second one raw but there's better ways
to do it you can use the name of the of
the city to to calculate this if you
want to know of the distance between two
cities so yeah we can calculate this and
it gives us some number and this number
is in kilometers and this is one of the
biggest numbers because I think one of
the the second one was Alaska so the
distance is bigger okay so basically now
we have this function it works for two
points but we want to yes if I if I
wanted to use log I should specify the
name of the of the index so that's the
difference between oh that's a mistake
I should be consistent yes that in this
case they're both I think the index is
the same as the number it doesn't matter
but yeah that should be should be
consistent I think in this case you just
because the index is just the name of
the index in 0 1 2 so it's pretty much
the same whether you use lock or I lock
just just to clarify if if I had some
names here like I had actual names of
cities and index then it's better to use
lock but because I have numbers it's the
same with the index location and the
location number name so this is like a
detail about on data frames and how you
have their indices yeah I think the
right way to do it is if we really cared
we should have made this column maybe be
the index and then we can use the names
to compare distances or or even the
state so that it's more more explanatory
okay so anyway this is just an example
between two points and we need to do it
between all the pair's right so so how
do we do that in general how would we go
about doing calculating distance between
all pairs of points how would you write
your own program to be any ideas what is
the simplest way to do that
we have one set of points another set of
points how would you implement this in
any language couple of loops yeah so
that's kind of one of them you know if
you're not if it's the first thing to do
just to get it work that's what I would
do and in general that's kind of like
it's considered an inefficient way so
for such a small data set it doesn't
matter but when it when you have a lot
of points you actually don't have to go
through the the two loops because the
distance between a and B is the same is
in distance between DNA so there's kind
of efficient ways to go through pairs of
points and that's why there is this
function which is part of them
part of the Syfy package so we can run
it here so this function is called speed
East which is pretty much stays for
pairwise distances and in general if you
don't have anything here it's going to
calculate deep Lydian distances and the
nice thing about is that under the hood
they fold up the best way to kind of
calculate these distances so I don't
think they have two loops I think
they're more efficient data structures
to do with this problem so we'll just
use their function because they thought
already about it and instead of using a
standard distance which should be if we
don't have anything here we put our
function so basically we we substitute
our own action ok so now we can actually
have we can run that and we see that
when we run the speed East function what
we get is we get some object that is
just a vector so basically we get like a
list of distances while what we want is
I want to know what the distance with
between all I and J right so basically
on what this function is returning is
returning only half of like if we think
about the distance to be between every
pair of point to be like a matrix it
only returns half of these values
because it's more efficient right it
doesn't need to store the other half
because they're the same but it's not
it's not so you kind of it's a little
bit hard to say which distance is what
right there just a long list I mean
they're ordered but it's not that
intuitive so you can always go back to
the square matrix and for that you can
use this function which is called square
4 so it comes again from this distance
module inside PI so when we do that we
run that and we see that the shape
something went wrong let's rerun this so
the shape now is a square fifty-fifty
okay does it make sense
pretty much the first wing on contain
half of the values in these square
matrix and in a list now we have a
square matrix so we can say I J
corresponds to this distance okay so
this is how to get distances the next
step is to create a network out of these
distances so how do we do that well we
have to define what we mean by a network
and in this case I decided to define
that any two points would be connected
if their distance is less than 300
kilometers so basically I define what my
network is and when when I basically on
if I set this distance less than 300 I
get a matrix of zeros and ones and which
says whether two cities are connected or
are not connected and that matrix is
very important in general anytime you
work with networks because that that
matrix contains all the information
about the network because it tells us
that two nodes are connected or two
nodes are not connected so basically
describe the structure of the network
and it's called
odd adjacency matrix okay so we have
this matrix a and now that we have it we
can kind of dive into the Python package
we deduce with networks so that we can
kind of visualize visualize networks so
the package in Python for networks is
called like network s X of course there
are other packages but this is one of
the standard ones in the standard way to
import it is with this abbreviation and
X and then because we want to build the
matrix we want to do the network from
this matrix we use this
function from numpy metrics to create a
graph so basically I need to run this
before that so basically it created some
object with John which is called dream
and this object is a type graph so it's
a special object but the important thing
is that it contains the notes which here
just numbered from 0 to 50 and it also
contains the edges so so basically tells
us if two nodes are connected so it
stores the edge so basically from the
matrix form it stores the matrix in this
node edge away ok so so let's let's look
at it so in order to look at it we use
this draw function and it just draws the
network okay so that's what we get
does anybody have explanation of why we
get that and what does that mean um or
does it mean something at all
[Music]
so basically what what is the network
and network just tell that things are
connected or not connected because and
we didn't even put any way we just said
one or zero right connected not
connected so in some sense this is
correct because it put all the nodes and
it connected the right one there's
nothing wrong and there it is that it
arranged in this way is because in the
network there is nothing about the
distances right it's nothing about the
geographic information so pretty much
python is free to arrange these nodes
the way it likes and this layout is some
standard i think i'm sure that circular
layout so there's nothing wrong with
that although it doesn't look like we
expected it but it's not it's not wrong
but if we want to put more structure
then we can we can just add an extra
step and as an extra parameter here we
can add the longitude and the latitude
so pretty much you you specify the
layout and we can look at it this way
okay so now they are at least in the
right location they're not very visible
so that's why I added a few more steps
so I made the node size 20 in the node
color blue for difference and you get
one more on no clear image of where the
connections are so and then you can play
further round you can add titles and so
on but basically this is the way you
visualize on a network okay so we have
the network and as I said I want to kind
of learn something about about the data
set from the network so not from the
data directly but somehow through the
networks so as I said the adjacency
matrix describes the whole network the
whole graph in some sense
so pretty much we can do things with the
matrix itself and get things about about
the data set so what can we learn well
one of them one of the kind of like one
of the popular properties of for a node
of a network is the degree and this is
the number of edges that you have from
from a lot so okay so we can create we
can actually calculate it from the
adjacency matrix because each row tells
us how many connections this node has so
if we sum all the values on long Metro
we get the degree of the node does it
make sense
little bit of algebra but the point is
that we can get information so we can
basically get the degree of each node
and here we get the numbers and we can
build a diagonal matrix out of it and
because we use it in a in a second so
it's called the degree matrix okay so
there is another matrix that's very
useful and it's called the laplacian
matrix and that matrix is simply we get
the degree matrix and subtract that
Justin C matrix so just son matrix
doesn't mean much but it actually has a
lot of interesting properties so one of
them is that if we calculate the
eigenvalues of this matrix we'll get
information about the number of
connected components so from some
algebraic property we get some sort of
some sort of geometric property so let's
let's do that so let's calculate this
matrix because I believe it's useful and
then we're going to calculate the eigen
values and the eigen vectors for that we
can use the SyFy linear algebra
package and we just calculate eigen
values eigen vectors and then we're
going to plot them okay and I learned
actually I kind of didn't realize that
they don't come ordered so I had to sort
them so that they are ordered I guess I
expected them ordered but anyway we can
sort them and plot them so you see that
there are a lot of them which are zero
and a lot of them come kind of you know
you know chunk together sort of and then
some of them are separate okay so the
ones that are zero basically we need to
count how many of those are there and I
counted them already there like 22 and
that tells us that basically that the
null space of this matrix is of 22 which
on the other hand means that we have let
me so I think we have
yeah we have like 22 connected
components based on that okay
so let's let's look whether that's
correct I mean if you just from the from
the properties so let's look at this so
you can see that there are only a few
bigger components but each one of them
each of these guys is connected to
itself so it's already it's also a
connected component
so that's why if we count all of them
plus the few chunks like they're like 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 so 9 chunks and all the
single ones and you see that it's like
22 so kind of like you can on so for
this one it's easy to count them if I
have a network of million nodes I don't
want to count them by looking at them so
then you can just use these metrics to
calculate the number of connected
components ok so these are just kind of
nice interesting things or what else can
we get from these metrics there's some
other properties and I won't get into
them but you can kind of look at the
other eigen values and get something
that's called like on algebraic
connectivity which tells you how
connected the network is and so on so
basically you get other property so in
some sense it has to look like learn
about clusters in this network
okay so and just one final note is that
for this example I assume that the
network the Jason see consists of zeros
and ones
so pretty much I have H or no edge if I
actually took the distance and set that
distance to be the weight of the edge
instead of having cut off because I
decided like I arbitrarily decided that
less than 300 kilometers is the cutoff
right but I don't have to do that so
basically I can leave the distance as it
is it's going to be my weight and I can
kind of do the same steps like getting
the laplacian and so on and the
properties of the laplacian would
correspond to transfer of clusters in a
decent network so there's not going to
be a sharp cutoff like here here just
number of kinetic components there you
kind of look at eigenvalues and looking
for cut-offs and you can say more or
less okay this is the number of clusters
so it's a very nice feature when you
work with spatial data so pretty much on
when you have time you can kind of you
can actually redo this example with the
distance is not with the viewers and
months and you see that you get some
interesting information okay so so this
is kind of the this is what I wanted to
share with you on networks do you have
any questions regarding this on topic or
in general like how to go further from
this point on so there's a lot of kind
of like properties that you can kind of
start calculating later on so they have
names I mean it's kind of like you have
to look into the literature but they did
that once you can plot kind of visualize
them compute these matrices that are
important you have everything you need
and regarding like kind of working with
a larger or networks in that case
usually it's not good
work with the mattresses the way we kind
of get algebra here it was pretty nice
but for large networks that's pretty
expensive so if you work with the matrix
make sure that you store it is a sparse
matrix because then you just store the
edges that you had you don't store
things that are 0 or even further or you
you might kind of abolish the whole max
extinct order to kind of meet because
there's more efficient algorithms to
calculate connected components and so on
so like the breadth-first search and so
on so kind of like you you might have to
do more things sometimes the textbook
solutions might not work out directly ok
so this is about networks so it's
setting enough to people to get started
with their own projects um
the other topic that the next topic I
want to cover is working with working
with text and in order to work with text
that's very interesting
oh I have no idea why they oh maybe from
this one not you treat the T no password
okay so the next notebook that I'll go
through is code web scraping and text
mining and here I just kind of want to
get you started a little bit working
with text data and I combined it with
web scraping because in many cases you
get text data from the web so it kind of
goes together often so what is the data
we are going to work with well I decided
to work with with the data from the
abstracts of the PI data confirms so
basically we have this website right and
we have we have all the talks and each
talk if you go if you click on a link
you get information you we have a
description and you have an abstract so
and there is some text in after so
basically I wanted to learn what what is
this pi data conference about based on
the topics that we have or like we can
look at a conference from a previous
year and kind of learn about something
about it okay so so in order to get that
data what kind of steps we need to do so
you see that there is one website and
then each one goes to and somebody
doesn't have an abstract so we have a
like on empty an empty text so in order
to do that so before we even get to the
text we need to pretty much find all
these talks right in this website and
then for each talk we need to go and
grab the abstract from that other
website right so for each we need to do
a little bit of web scraping but why not
it's not too hard so let's go through
the steps for it so there's two packages
that's pretty much you need in order to
deal with all our web stuff so one of
them is URL Lib and this particular
package kind of the commands change
between Python 2 and Python 3 so if you
have python 2 you have to adjust a
little bit this notebook to make it work
but basically this gets you information
from links on the web and the other
package is called beautifulsoup which
pretty much scrape the whole website and
gets you information from the website so
they get together kind of give you
everything you need so all right so
first it's kind of the first step is to
get this on pretty much and get the
information from this schedule website
and if we do that let me split this if
we do that we get this object
Oh a LeBron again import things
so basically it gives us dawn because I
said to reach the giggles like an HTML
of the website with a lot of different
stuff so another web developer but you
can recognize I think that you know like
there's like a header and so on okay
so then to make kind of organize this
ugly shoot to a beautiful soup you use
this beautiful soup package which pretty
much with this kind of rich it's this
web page but organizes things by their
corresponding tax so I don't know all
the details about it but like the idea
is that it's just a little bit more
organized version of the original page
so okay so let's look at what this thing
is so this schedule it's in terms of
type it's a special type so it doesn't
give us much information it's some sort
of beautiful soup type of object but the
important thing is that we can use the
find command to find things in this
object alright so so let's go and we
have something very specific in mind
that we want for example in this case if
we look at all the HTF links we find
pretty much all the links in this
website and we scroll down and we see
they're like some of the the vein links
and so on but the ones we were
interested in is the one that say
schedule presentation and some number so
these are all the presentations right so
so we know that we we want only those to
get the links of the talks so I just
kind of add this extra condition that I
want to grab all the ones that are
linked
if there is this scheduled presentation
in that link so and these are the ones I
want so I use of I use a list
comprehension which are just makes it
shorter but sometimes less clear but
they gave that it's still readable
intuitively right intuitively we want
all of these if that is inside on inside
the link and I added the beginning of
the website which is a PI data dot work
so that I have the home link okay so
with that line we should get all the
links shown so we get all the links now
right okay so so as you see this in you
know from the front website you don't
really know what you're looking for you
have to kind of dig into these things to
see that this is the think that it's
gonna involve scheduled presentation so
in a sense it involves a little bit of
like looking into it but then you can
kind of grab watching me alright so we
have this list of links now so for each
link now we want the abstract so we're
going to do the same thing we did before
that we going to first use the euro URL
open to open that link so what this is
just the first link for example and then
I'm going to use the beautifulsoup to
organize things in that link so let's
let's look at this actually let's click
them again
so talk webpage is again a ugly HTML
document and and then we can parse it
with beautiful soup so what do we need
now like if we kind of scroll here
somewhere
I don't know where but somewhere here
and
oh so here there is the statement which
starts class abstract and then after
that the abstract follows so this is
kind of the indicator to tell us where
the abstract is I mean I have to look at
it to figure it out I didn't know in
advance because I didn't know how they
wrote the webpage but now that I have
that I can pretty much grab this whole
on kind of object with the text so how
do we do that well we specify that we
want this disk class that's called
abstract and we also want to just get
the text from it so that's that's all so
let's do that and then we look at it and
we just get the text from it so for
every class you can specify the class
and the name and you can get the text
corresponding to that part on the way
okay so now we have actual text that's
we can on we can all work with okay so
what do we do with text when we get text
you see there there's like on there is
someone or in lines and you might need
to do a little bit of pre-processing
before before you start working so there
are a few steps that are very typical
when working with text that usually
people do depends on the task but people
often do on so energy K is on one of the
most popular natural language on on to
boxes in Python and in order to use that
you can first run import and ltk so it's
part of anaconda so you should have it
working but what's not there it's not if
you haven't used it before you don't
have any so in order to use these two
boxes you need some sort of like
dictionary somewhere to tell you
can you do something with text to kind
of check in that dictionary what what
what's a word and what's not a word so
on so in order to get those if you
haven't done it before you can run this
command and ltk download and it should
open a window which in my case now I run
it before that so everything is
installed but if you haven't done it
before you can go and install them so
that you have them in the future and
they take some space if you don't have
space I think this is sufficient all
energy K so you don't have to run them
all if you want to have them for the
future you can run them but figure out
whether you have enough space on your
laptop so then you don't click download
here and you have in the future you have
it and you won't need to run this
anymore so it's just like a first step
thing so this is basically these are
this corpora which contain the
information for the English language or
for some other language
so and it has information about what the
verb was a pronoun and so on so much
more than just some sort of tricks ok so
we call this and might take a little bit
of time to download it so just because
it's a whole image so say my case I
already have them so I can start on
using them and so one of the typical
steps to start with is to sort of get
this abstract which is just a long
string right now it's on it's a string
and convert it to some sort of words
which are called
kind of like meaningful objects which
are called tokens so in order to do that
there are different tokenizer to use and
one of them is called the REC X regular
expression tokenizer and you can
basically pick that one
and there are other tokenizer there's
slight details but they did to convert
the string to some sort of meaningful
objects and that Python can understand
how to work with so if you do that we'll
use these red X tokenizer and will
convert the abstract into tokens and
what are tokens well in some times these
are the words but there are details
about not just splitting my space it's
being a little bit more than that but
anyway we have now some sort of a split
split abstract so what else we should do
is because if we want to compare to
other abstracts we should synchronize on
it doesn't really matter whether
something is capitalized or not it's the
same word right so that's why it's
usually useful to convert all the tokens
lowercase it is kind of like a typical
step to do so with this lower command
which is just a command for string we
can convert all the tokens to lowercase
tokens
so we got them lowercased okay what else
what else can we do we can remove those
stop words so that's where the corpus is
helping cause it tells us what are the
stop words well so here there is just
done what are the stop words let's just
look at them
so these are the stop words in this
corpus actually don't know how
officially what is the official
definition of a stop word but there's a
lot of pronouns and so on so so let's
remove those because maybe they're not
that meaningful it depends what you want
but in this case I don't think it
matters so
so basically with this one line we say
that we want all the lower tokens if
they are not in the stop words so we
will eliminate the stop words okay and
the last step that is usually useful and
I think there are a lot more I'll just
give you a few examples is to to stem
the words and the reason is that if you
have like dancing or dance doesn't
matter we you know like what it might be
important whether it does it now or test
before but in this case most probably we
just want to know that it's something
about dancing so it doesn't really
matter what the ending is so we care
about the route so that's why we get
usually when we we want to do some text
processing we stamp the text so that we
just get the route which sometimes
becomes like I'll show you that when we
do that here sometimes it's hard to get
even what they came from so let's look
at them some of them are okay but none
of them become so short that so these
are sort of okay like main memory I
guess so yeah how many come very short
so it's a little bit harder to guess
later on what the word was
but it's kind of usually the right
approach
yeah similar this also in this case we
need this one caster procedure or method
but there are other ones and I actually
don't know
you know I guess they're different
routes how to do that and this is just
one of them one caster and they have
names like with different methods so
yeah I guess using a different methods
you get slightly different on results so
I think depending on the application
this application I think of it more like
oh let's learn about the topics it
doesn't matter so much but if it's
something you want to learn more about
the type of language that they're
speaking or something like that must
know it's important okay so these are
like a few steps there could be more
steps to adding but usually that we have
to do some pre-processing sometimes okay
so the next step is like basically is to
organize this and this we just weed it
on one abstract but we have like on I
think like sixty abstracts to get on so
the edges to to on to put it in a
function so that if you need to apply to
any abstract and I think it's pretty
easy I actually have the answer after
that means nothing I think the main
point is to kind of pay attention to the
steps that you have and add the
functions that you want so so basically
we create these functions so pretty much
by copying and pasting the previous
steps you create these own functions you
can kind of get for yourself but it's
really nothing there
I just copied pasted in the previous
command and put them into a function so
that if you need to apply to every
abstract so it's like my people
I think a function okay so so once we
have that we can apply to every abstract
so basically I made the function that it
works on my URL because I had a whole
list of URLs so now I can apply these
pre-processing to every to every link so
if I do that I mean I basically I can
run a forward to do that but I'm using
these these comprehensions just because
I feel like using them but the main
point is we apply this function to every
URL in the list okay so we should run
this first
and that takes time actually please it
needs to do stuff right so so I don't
know how long it takes but they did that
um so in the end what we're going to get
is we're going to get a list of lists
because we had a fridge abstract we had
all these tokens and so the tokens were
released by themselves so that's what
our text would look like so in order to
do like kind of learn something like
summary statistics about about what in
the PI data conference one of the
approaches that we can use is to extract
some topics from this text which is a
typical approach when you have like
bunch of documents and you want to learn
something about it the individual words
might not mean that much but you want to
find common themes Spanish words so so
this is a standard technique and it
relies on some sort of counts basically
so like here we get as I said we we have
65 abstract each one consists of these
words in some sense so we can think that
if we want to represent the text
numerically so that we can be sum up
some math on it or like on statistics we
we can kind of look at the histogram
right and we can see which words appear
more often and which would appear less
often and so on
so basically this can give us a lot of
information for each document by getting
a histogram of the words so like the
word count and on the other hand if we
see that the word appears very often in
a text like data for example but if this
word appears in every of the abstracts
so that's not really not interesting
because well all of them you know every
abstract is about data so I don't learn
anything specific so that's why there is
basically there is the notion of terms
frequency which as I said is the
frequency of each term in a document but
then there is also the inverse document
frequency which pretty much tells you if
a word appears often across all
documents then it's not that interesting
so we scale down the weight so in a
sense we want words that appear a lot in
some document and are sort of unique
also to these documents so that's kind
of the idea so if we build such an
object then we can kind of do some on
some operations on it to get the topics
so it is like a typical making this is a
standard approach to build this term
frequency inverse document frequency
matrix and on and from then you can do a
lot of things with it so you can
actually do it yourself
so I actually encourage you as an
exercise to to try and build such a
matrix yourself but python has like on
Python has some ways to do it for you
but I think it's useful to actually try
to create one for yourself so in order
to use the Python ones though it's a
little bit I think there's a way around
it but in this case I had to go back to
strings again right you remember we
converted the text to tokens we stamped
everything and we get a list of tokens
but in order to use them count the
counting functions in a invitin I had to
go back to shrink again which is
basically what this on these few steps
are doing so it's really not
it's not don't wander too much on it it
basically converts converting back to
string and I think there is a way to
avoid that so I'm sure somebody can
figure out another function but the
function that I wanted to use which is
basically this tf-idf vectorizer require
to string again so I had to go back to
string let's make sense it was more of a
like Python details
[Applause]
so actually I want you to try think
maybe I'll give you like maybe five
minutes I want you to try to do it
yourself
I think it's useful exercise if you even
if you don't have loaded everything just
try to think a little bit of how you'd
write a function to do it by yourself to
basically create a matrix of counts for
each word so I guess I should go to this
link
so maybe here is a good example so
pretty much we have over documents along
one line and we have the joint set of
words on the other line so the joint
because there's going to be some words
in one document and another set of words
in another document but we want to build
sort of the whole language so the total
number here would be the total number of
unique words and we pretty much first we
wanna get Butte like a term frequency
matrix which is just a number of count
and then we can kind of scale it up to
divide by the document frequency so you
can kind of look at the the actual
definition but first I just want you to
build the matrix of of term frequencies
don't even worry about the inverse to
that just a useful exercise and then
we'll just use the we'll just use the
Python function but I just want you to
try to see how it how it works and then
you can even compare the speed so I'll
give you like five minutes to play with
it and if you haven't loaded everything
just think of the front and I think how
you dry the function even on paper just
as an exercise
and you can chat with your neighbor if
you want to there are different ways to
do that
please
so so this ar-15 Congrats to somewhere
so here you live already please you got
the Jupiter stocks and cuz some part of
it is there so can we look at the
terminal where we try to run it with all
its kind of asking I think try to ask me
this about the one time on
identification what if you follow these
steps with this token and this video
sucks because characters yeah I think
just following that my dear um I I've
got only sometimes and I don't know why
occasionally test me for this token and
you're going to ask you for our token in
German abilities there and hopefully
that would open the logbook and I I saw
the Anaconda
it's going to just help England you
could go to a burger shop no actually
the times
thank you know that it started coming up
with some newer versions I think once
you set it up you won't need to do that
very well but there is something that
when you initially so much
I am trying this on the counter
I haven't installed the one person and
what I went to on the upper-left corner
with dart network so that's why I was
there so I wonder whether that's linked
to your can you just put it off I don't
know Michael can you just cut it off I
don't know what's in it
oh yeah can you run Python I just want
to see what version independent branch
what is talking to your own a condo here
should be do knock on the one you don't
have another version a second
doesn't anaconda we have an installed
another one because everything okay does
what I'm wondering what it's for sealing
the bushes for the armored coma I think
if you set up like there is a way to set
up that it becomes your default and I
thought 2001 inducing stolen you wanted
me to reinstall it I think just maybe
check on I think there is like something
to add to your startup path so that like
in your profile so that it knows that
it's on which version you want so you
can just google the how to do it on
Windows I know how to do it on a matter
yeah but I think there's be startup file
which is for like settings for us
anything you need to just add the
Anaconda path there and hope food and
every time you run Python you're going
to get down a condo on so it might be
confusing the other one yeah I think
when I okay I think when I install it
maybe I didn't check that back yeah I
think it's like a few things like you
want to do these places but you can set
it up after that so you won't need it to
install directory yeah okay this is your
color that's perfect yeah check that
should make sure that we get the right
workshop in that thing should be working
but I don't know maybe that's what
there's all that I don't all Triforce to
fix the past
Oh
[Music]
so any of what kind of ideas came from
what kind of ideas came from the
discussion anybody actually implemented
this or have an idea of how to implement
it
there are different ways to do this I
just wonder what kind of approaches
people hold up or what kind of
difficulties you you fault you encounter
if you have to do that so what if we
want to do two one one role for one
document right maybe that's the simplest
step for students we have one abstract
we want to have for each word we want to
know the number of times the word
appears how do we do that
yeah you just do like a loop through the
tokens and like they like it and like
stores it as ads like so for each token
if it already is in like some separate
list then don't put it and with it all
right
yeah so you like you would for each
token if it's already in the separate
like vector then you you wouldn't put it
in but you would put it as like a count
and then if it does you're like checking
I don't think I'm watching what I want
I do want to live through all of the
tokens within that document and keep
account yeah so basically we go through
the document if we see a word for a
first time we set up like a container
for it like it going to be one or all of
these metrics and if we see it again we
add plus one and if we see a new word we
add a new row something like that kind
of and we start building though no ask
you like to first look like adding it
for different documents and there's new
terms but is that like bureaus yeah so
basically we knew she ate I guess we
could initiate all the terms initially
like by looking at the joint text from
all the documents like the total the
distinct work that appear we can use a
set for that right if we want to get
like on just the unique elements we can
set the elements all the tokens and then
set it to zero then if we see to start
adding one plus plus one plus two so
yeah that's kind of what one approach
any other approaches people photos like
using other sometimes some other
libraries this kind of like the pure
Python approach any other ideas
yes vector of all the birds and that
it's going to be the same for every
document and we can just go through and
increment appropriately Thank You Samuel
earth and ears and then concatenate okay
so in your case you set first the vector
of all the words right so you fix you
know so you don't like otherwise in your
example you kind of if you hear a new
one you append right in your case you're
going to allocate sort of this vector so
you're just going to be adding the zeros
and ones so that kind of the difference
yeah that's another approach so yeah
like I think these are getting to the
little details that if these matrices
are big you know like that then these
things would matter whether we take one
approach or another approach like for
example if we can allocate all the
memory then it's better to allocate it
in advance if on the other hand is the
total number will never fit into our
memory then it's actually better to do
the appending approach and kind of do it
pin by piece because depending can work
as long as you keep on adding things you
don't have to load everything in the
thing so these are kind of different
approaches and I'll add a few more that
are more based on on on I think they're
just based on some I'll just show you
some more function that exists pretty
much to do the existing item to be
something like that and they might be
useful for other things so there is
something called collections this is
like collections in general right on
collections so this is just a sub
package and what does it have it has
named people this is a little bit more
general Python thing but I think it's
useful so it has a named tuple so if you
actually know what the tuple is name
table so triple doesn't have names
sometimes you really want to have names
which is named tuple there is DQ on
something like something that can talk
things out so the one that I the reason
I'm showing this to you is the dirtiest
pink coat counter and that's kind of a
useful in this situation when you pretty
much do discounting so this pretty much
does what your approaches are suggesting
like every time you get a new one it
keeps on counting so you can kind of
look back on and see how to use it
anytime you need to do something
counting like that like histograms you
can use this counter container which is
a special container in Python and let's
see if they have an example
until you don't like their examples but
maybe I'm not reading careful anyway if
you need histogram use code so that's
like a histogram of the words we need
use counter and check an example how to
use it I'm not reading carefully so but
that's what it is used useful for so and
I'll just mention this since we're on
this page this is independent
dictionaries in Titan if you have used
them you know that they don't have order
and that's why they have the property
that they have their design not to have
order but sometimes you really want to
have something with an order they have
something called order dictionary so and
you can convert the dictionary into
ordering dictionary so it's just useful
in general since we're on this
collection spring all right so let's
let's get back so and I think also
another thing is pandas has a histogram
or a histogram function so which works
with with drinks with words so you can
use that basically it's going to do like
a histogram because like if you use
other functions like a from numpy
they're designed for numerical numbers
so they won't work with the strings they
won't work with the word but python has
pandas have some history so yeah
different approaches but as I said
python has a whole function to do to do
this build this matrix for you so you
really don't have to do it I just wanted
you to think about how you do it so and
the functionality is using this on this
so pretty much now we're jumping in to
cycle on package which has several prop
several functionalities to extract
features from text and one of them is to
really do this matrix because it's a
famous matrix so we get these
tf--idf vectorizer and these details
here pretty much tell us whether we want
a word to appear at least twice so you
get like a minimum bound by default is
one but if you want to set up
I want this word only if it appears that
Lisa twice then you can set about and if
a word appears in 95% of the documents
more than 95% of the documents you want
to use it because it's too popular so
you set some bounds on which words you
want and basically after that you just
applied Islam fit transfer function to
your abstract so basically there's a lot
of like name here but the main point is
that we import this package we
initialize it and in Toronto in Poland
and we get the matrix so and you see
that the matrix is sparse which is good
because in general you want to store
these on usually you won't have the same
words in all the text so you have a lot
of zeros so like not the same words
appear in all the documents but the
dictionary is big so um so you want a
sparse matrix so that you can manipulate
it better okay and in this case it's not
that big it's 65 documents so it gets
587 words so our dictionaries really
small okay so now back to back to some
linear algebra and again just getting
this matrix we can do manipulations on
the matrix and get interesting
information just by applying some
transformation so the method that I'll
go through is called a non-negative
matrix factorization and it's one of the
popular approaches to find topics they
did that we just want to take this
matrix and split it into topics and ways
so basically we decompose the matrix
into a linear combination of topics so
you can read more about the math behind
it but I'll just show you how to use it
now and then see what we get out of it
okay so in this case I set the number of
topics to five the number matters in a
sense that if you run five and if you
run for clearly you get one more topic
but you also get different topics so
keep it in mind the number matters a lot
it's not like nested so anyway I picked
five and I import in a map from
scikit-learn a composition package if
you view scikit-learn before you might
have on
let's split this if you use it you might
have used a PCA from it it's pretty
popular approach principal component
analysis but together with PCA there's a
lot of other functions and one of them
is NMS and the reason we want nmf is
because we want the weights to be
positive so that they represent some
sort of probability of being from this
topic or that topic there is a lot of
details behind it and kind of
interpretation but I'll just show you
how to do that so okay so we import nmf
and there's time initialization doesn't
matter so much or you don't even need to
set it right you can use the default
ones and then you just get done the two
matrixes which one is corresponding to
weight the other one is corresponding to
topics in some sense so we just run it
like this so let me show you now what
these objects are that we got in terms
of dimensions so the shape of the W
matrix is 665 and 5 in the shape of them
the H matrix is 5 and 587 so what degree
are like so we have 5 topics and we can
represent um pretty much we can
represent all each document with these
five topics so this would be the weights
for the first matrix 65 is the number of
documents and you so basically get
weights for each document
for the individual topics so you can
represent each document for the topics
on one hand on the other hand you can
represent on each topic with all the
words so depending on what words you get
here
so basically gives you representation of
the topics on one hand and of how the
documents are represented with these
topics so as I said you can read more
about it but it's important to look at
the dimensions could they tell you what
which Matrix Switch okay so the H
contains the topics and kind of the last
statement pretty much what it does is
that it takes the first ten words for
each topic and it just displays them and
based on those words we try to guess or
what this topic so we call a topic but
the truth is it might not be that
meaningful so let's run that and as I
said it's just you just bring some
sorting in extracting ten words for each
topic nothing much more than that so
these are the topics that we got and I
looked at them and I cannot say what
they mean
so that's good because that means that
we need to improve this method
because I looked at them and kind of the
idea was to just guess first of all
though this is maybe more statistical
covariance is forecasting cost well then
we got hardware so yeah I don't know so
that that's where that these are the
topics of PI data conference
I guess just everything so they were
that we can talk about everything at the
same time we don't need one topic so
yeah I mean anyway this is kind of like
on just an exercise I just wanted to use
that data set and you can actually play
with it and try to get you can play with
the number of components you can play
with the pre-processing part maybe you
remove some work that don't matter and
so on so maybe you can get some
meaningful topics out of it and just a
little note to to tell you in general so
with abstract these are very short
document so it's much harder to do topic
modeling with short documents because
usually words appear like like one or
two times I mean it's a short it's not
like if you have like a whole book on
biology you're going to get like five
million biology terms appearing over and
over again so that's why these are the
like dumb the term frequency approach it
works very well with Wikipedia articles
and so on but you know these are very
short so it becomes tricky so you have
to think more of what a good approach to
P do that okay and here I just have a
few final things to say about them what
you do if you have like god if you have
like a lot of documents it's kind of a
little bit regarding the discussion of
how to even calculate these matrices so
the important thing is that everything
you do you can separate document by
document when you do these counts or
when you do the pre-processing you can
split it you can paralyze it you can run
it on different computers you can share
with your roommates I do want you do
another one so on that's good thing
about this approach and
there are some libraries which can deal
with this like on so so dusk is a Python
library which can do all you can do the
counting kind of like without loading
everything at the same time and spark
has the M leap library so that can spark
kind of a similar approach to this so
you can kind of go and explore how to do
that and in this case you don't have to
load everything ok so that's that's all
about text I have to say any questions
on the text topics in general like on
and I'm just dealing with Python and
text yes yeah so actually there is
another package in a Python which is not
part of anaconda but it's called Ninfa
and one of the goals of nymph of items
one of the goals of this package is to
to play with the cost and pretty much
they run these automatically for you
they try to find the optimal number of
components and also when I say
non-negative matrix factorization
there's a lot of different ways to
implement it so they basically focus on
comparing all these different ways
different costs so so it's kind of one
way to study there is no one correct
solution so pretty much we tested and we
look at the resulting on that's kind of
the approach to do that
any other questions okay so we'll jump
into on the next topic which is the hunt
notebook because I want you to introduce
you to some sounds processing in Python
okay so in this case first of all I'll
grab some I'll grab some kind of like
music database and you know we'll do
something with some music online the
truth is it's not that simple and the
reason is that you know there's the
copyright so you can't just grab some
database of music and usually they have
features of the forms but they don't
have the raw songs and there are some
databases which you can access the raw
data but it would in another format so
anyway so that led me to to on to use
the bird sound database because bird
sounds don't have a copyright I guess I
mean they have a copyright but it's not
that restrictive so there is this
website which is kind of interesting
it's called say no Reno Council where
people it's like crowdsourcing website
in which people record sounds of birds
and they upload them and then people
like annotate them and so on so you have
like a lot of us recording the bird
songs and from that website there is
another data set which was a little bit
hard to get data in bulk from it so
anyway there is another data set that
somebody shared and I used and you can
kind of download it for yourself if you
want to play so it's basically just to
organize subsets of one of the database
so anyway it's loading but there is a
link to the data set that I'll be using
so pretty much this is just a subset
some people kind of annotated and sift
and put on the nodal and you can
download it as long as inside it the way
they asked you to cite it and use their
license okay so anyway I downloaded this
and there's like a bunch of fun dot wave
WAV files which are music files there
and there is just to read them and play
with them in Python okay so first we
just run these standard packages in
order to read a dot web file in on in
Python or one of the simplest way to do
it is to use the sci-fi dog IAP on
package which has a lot of i/o like
input/output with different formats and
one of them is the web woof I don't know
how to pronounce it the wasps are was
with extension anyway interestingly you
don't have mp3 and the reasoning that
mp3 has its own licensing like on kind
of local conditions so when they try to
merge it with other packages like which
are have more users than the license
they don't work together so you find
that a lot of things a lot of like
standard packages in in anaconda don't
have mp3 and mp4 functionality just
because of those licensing or details
but anyway these are not mp3 so we can
directly read them using the log file
huit function so let's run this and in
terms of the four months it's pretty
simple so I store it into something
called board sound and it has two things
in it you see that
kind of the length is - it contains two
elements one of them is just the first
element is just the frequency and the
second element is basically the signal
so it's pretty simple representation
from then on you can kind of do you know
you get it into icon now Python and you
can do whatever you want with it you
don't have to worry about the format and
just one note that in this case these
are these had only one channel but
sometimes you can have like depending on
the camera you can have a multi-channel
signal so you have instead of one
dimensional thing here you have a
multi-dimensional kind of object so you
have your channels so just keep these in
mind but otherwise it's pretty simple so
okay so it's just one dimensional so we
can actually plot it let's just do that
here
so that's what it is this is the sound
of the song and in this case when I plot
it you can see that the axis the the
time axis is kind of off because it's
just showing the frame in the signal
which is not nice right you want to show
the true time so in order to do that you
can use the frequency to adjust it so in
this case birth sound zero is the
frequency the first element and then you
can pretty much take divide the the the
frame number by the frequency to get a
real time so and then you get something
like that and that's now seconds so you
know the real time
seven seconds something like okay so
this is what signal if you can read it
now you can actually play it which is
kind of neat so this is using the
ipython display functionality so you
just import these things and on and we
can write if it works so I listen to
this while preparing this and then I
started hearing these the same sound
everywhere like this all the time and I
don't even know which type it is but you
don't hear it on to you there's like I'm
pretty sure it's the same one so so okay
so that's how you do with sound and you
see that you know in general when you
work with sound you kind of the signals
are you have to do a little bit you know
like sometimes standard methods don't
work because you have these like up and
downs and you know like the frequency
matters not just those down the
amplitude so you have to do a little bit
more so usually what people do is apart
from looking at the Sun they also look
at the spectrogram so the spectrogram is
basically on what it does is how to show
you the picture first and recall what it
is so what it does is it looks at this
on
first of all it looks at all different
frequencies and calculates like a window
for your transport so in the end you get
this kind of all sometimes like a 2d
representation of the signal which is
usually it's more informative than of
just the one key representation so and
the good thing is that because it's kind
of like an image you can kind of see
patterns and you can extract on it's
kind of like people a lot of these
people who actually studied birds they
can look at the spectrum and they know
which bird is right by the pattern that
they get so they know which which birth
it is which I think it's harder just
from the from the signal so so in this
case you can kind of like in terms of
approaches of dealing with South you can
work with directly with the with the
with the house but in many cases you can
just go ahead and start working with the
spectrogram and extract features from
the spy program instead constructing
certain features from the sound and do
some analysis on it so sometimes you
might need to do image processing
without really having real images so
that's one of the main points I kind of
wanted to make that you never know when
you need what so it might as well learn
how to do these things and you might
just get data that looks like that okay
so I'll say like just a few things
regarding that I won't get too much into
the features that people extract you can
read more about this in general like on
it depends really on your problem and
what you try to do but one of the
important things is that when you have
sound is that first of all let's look at
an example so
let's just plot - I want to plot two
different things so this is on this is
song one let's try to get another one
I just want to get two signals
so a little too
so just plot these two ones so this
color I think from the same species
hmm
okay so I need to look at the second
element so remember it was just the
second element with the signal so let's
do that okay so these are two different
songs but if you see you know in reality
one of them's just I think it's like
around one second the other one is like
the whole sequence so you know if you
try to do some analysis on on these kind
of like on this one songs well there
first of all they're different dimension
right there are different lengths they
might not be aligned I mean pretty much
you don't know whether this corresponds
to this part or this part or this part
so that is that there are some things
that you have to do that you don't do
normally when you work with other
datasets basically regarding like the
time alignment and so on so one way to
approach this is to to in some sense
search for patterns like in this case
this is just one chunk and try to find
the best pattern to fit this into this
song can see whether they have like some
overlap or not so let's look at some
example so
so in this case I automated the reading
of the files using these glop function
you can look at it later on but the main
point is to extract all the chunks for
all the files in the folder and those
are drumming we can position to one from
ink do that
let's drumming
just for fun a way so the drumming the
there signal looks like this so these
are two different ones and I plot them
together and you see the pattern is kind
of similar but they're they're just not
aligned I don't know whether it's easy
to distinguish boards by just by their
drumming actually I don't know but
anyway the point is that if I want to
compare these two sounds and I want to
see whether they're the same on the same
boat or something like that you know I
first need to do something to make sure
that this pattern on get aligned and
does anybody remember how to do that
there's one approach to try to adjust
this
what kind of years you have so
cross-correlation right so basically
here there is like a mismatch if we can
calculate the correlation between all
the pairings hopefully attempt on it's
going to be maximum at some point so the
main idea that you calculate for
different lags so if you think of
covariance you just calculate it for one
signal you calculate you square
everything but for cross correlations
you take one signal and you keep on
moving it and multiply the values in
some black they're going to match so
that's kind of the idea conceptual and
so if we find it what shift we get the
maximum correlation we can just shift it
in the line them in order to do that in
Python there is actually a NP correlate
function but I don't think that it has
such a light but I think it's not on I
think it's not the most efficient way to
do it and the most efficient way to do
it is to use of Fourier transforms and
this is kind of another like a little
trick to to remember from school that
you can actually get cross correlation
only by Fourier transforms so I won't
get into the
details but pretty much if you if you
reverse the signal 100 signals and you
calculate and you can walk those two
signals you get the cross correlations
subject like that anyway so the main
point is we can do it and here are the
steps to do it within a few details
because you need to pretty much you have
one song you have another song reversed
and there are some details of how to
deal with the boundaries so and then
because of that you need to do you kind
of find the maximum correlation but you
need to adjust because they're of
different lengths so you can check the
details later but the main point is that
there is a there is a step to do there
is an approach to do that and if we do
it with Fourier transplants it's going
to be efficient or inefficient if it can
get ok so let's let you do that
so we get some offset and on in this
case we got negative offset so they need
that I have to move against I have to
move to I need to move the first one
backwards on but because I cannot move
the first one backwards in terms of
indices I move the second one forward
something like that so ok so this kind
of got sort of aligned and I don't claim
that this is done the best we can
achieve and one note is about this
approach that it only looks at on linear
shift so if there is some stretching
that's not going to work so you have to
think of other ways to do that there are
ways to work the signals to match them
and so on so there's a lot of things to
do but the main point is that you have
to do when you work with sound you have
to do a few extra steps to get to the
point of doing the things you know how
to do and for this one like I think once
you kind of align them you can you can
kind
of now calculate some distance in
between them and kind of based on the
approach from the first discussion once
we have distances we can actually build
a network and we can study similarities
clusters and so on and this way we can
actually cluster the different species
so also basically you can once you get
to that point you can use the same
approaches as of the first part okay so
as I here I have some general questions
of how you can do that and it opens at
this point like because you can do this
on the signal but you can also shift the
spectrograms and align the spectrograms
instead so there's a lot of
possibilities okay in the last few
minutes I'll just show you one more
example and I'll stop so the last
example we have is to work with on with
video just for a difference so I have a
very short notebook in which I have only
one video and I'll show you let me see
if I can show you the view
so this was just something shot on
campus when we had the cherry on the
cherry blossoms and you know how you
want to get the picture of everything of
the background and all these people in
front of you so the question is how do
we how do we extract from this video the
background because I just want a picture
of the cherries it's a simple computer
vision problem all right so let's let's
do that quickly so we have them we have
a video and as I said there is a little
bit of a trouble with mp3 and mp4 and to
the best of my knowledge I don't think
there is a way just with pure anaconda
to read and before you need to install
extra packages unfortunately so there is
a way to read tip files if you have
sequences of images but if your videos
come from the camera they won't be
teased so you have to install some extra
stuff so one package that is pretty
light and I like although it's not the
most efficient one is called image IO
and you can install it using the content
store commands as nothing too bad is
just you need to make the extra step and
that package might require another
package which is super powerful and
working with videos is called ffmpeg and
and if you don't have it there is a step
to do solid it can download it on your
computer and I'm saying here like once
you get to ffmpeg it a little bit
depends on your system so that's why
there's always issues with dependencies
so it's a little bit harder to develop
Python code for videos because there's
always these travels with on these are
library dependencies so keep it in mind
but I think is one clean approach to do
with that first install in each i/o and
then setup ffmpeg through in each i/o
it's kind of like a it's like a trick
otherwise you need to install things
separately okay I have it set up on my
computer so I haven't
but I hope it works for you with these
steps too but in my case I already have
it and I have the video so I just so I
just go through the steps and when image
I all kind of like the first step is to
get this sort of link to the video it
doesn't do anything it doesn't read it
because reading a whole video it
actually is expensive but this is a way
to set a link to the video and then you
can decide which frames you want and in
this case for example if I want to just
get the first frame I just do get data
and I display the first frame you can go
further and so on but in in our case I
want to read the whole video but I want
to read the whole one because it's kind
of expensive so I'll skip like every 50
frames and try to do something with that
because even one video it becomes some
it becomes trouble to work with it okay
so I'll read that and I do have two
steps while reading it I'll just show
you so I just decided to take the first
channel so the video is like a kind of
pixels raw pixels : pixels and three
colors but I just take the first color
just to make it smaller and this
function rather it just makes it a long
vector so all I'm doing it on reading
the video is a long vector and so
because I read it is a long vector the
shape of this final thing is on so 50 is
the number of frames I'm reading and
this is the total number of pixels in a
frame okay so now I just have a matrix
and I'll apply the same method that we
apply on the text now apply it on the
video and I claim that if I do that I
can
actually extract the background so I'll
apply non-negative matrix factorization
on this matrix it's positive why not
let's let me compose it and I set the
number of components to one because in
this case I I just want the background I
don't really care about other other kind
of components I just want to get the
background so I said that and pretty
much run the same steps that we did
before like in the previous example and
that will take time because now it's
much bigger so it to take one more time
if we had the full video so these things
start to become very expensive and once
it's finished it's going to show it's
going to show the result but I can say a
few word about what to do in off when
there is no space so in general like now
videos are getting bigger and bigger
they're like 4k whatever that causes
travel like working with them even one
of them cannot fit into Ram so some
approaches to deal with that is so there
is something called in Python memory
mapping which kind of creates a it is
for any non PI array it stores it on the
disk and then you can have access to
every frame from disk so it takes more
space but it's very efficient if you
want the third frame xx fine so if you
want to access your video very often you
first store it into this memory mapped
object and then you can access it so
hdf5 is another format which kind of
doing something similar but it's more
general it's not just for python so
people know what you can transfer it
from one place to another main point is
you can access frames independent we
don't have to read actually for what we
are doing now in order to get to the
whatever frame I have to read I have to
search for it so it's kind of full so
and as I mentioned before there's the
desk library which using backs when
works with text but if you want to work
with images you have something called
Dockery which is pretty much the same
idea as memory map and hdf5 kind of you
can parallel life things in to store
things on on on the disk in some sense
so yeah I think these are kind of there
is no magic I mean if you have you to
use you can use them but that requires
hardware yes so yes so that's that
that's all I have
this is still running will it's going to
finish at some point so let's let me
know what kind of questions you have if
you have any questions yes it's hard to
say um many pycharm
is the best choice I use a term which is
just like I'm kind of like on just on
editor which you can add extra packages
to it to make it the way you like it
so yeah I'll take either pycharm or
Eitan or you can use the notebooks to
play around but they're not very good
for development so yeah
[Applause]